So next, I will attempt to make my program wait for a certain period of time.
To find about this, I went back to
Google, and then typed python make my program wait.
One of the first links there was this
website called stackoverflow.com. Now this will soon become
one of your favorite websites as a programmer.
it suggested to use something called time.sleep which suspends
the program for a given number of seconds. Okay, back to the program. Now since
I'm still in testing phase I will try to suspend the program only for about ten
seconds; we can change this number later. I also know that I have to import the
time module. Okay, let's save this and run. Alright.
It seems like the program is waiting for a few seconds before it
opens the web browser.
[MUSIC]
Another item bites the dust.